i don't know if you happen to see this
tweet from tampax which i guess
probably you shouldn't see it because
who follows a tampon brand on twitter
uh but this one went viral so a lot of
people saw it and the tweet was
fact not all women have periods also a
fact
not all people with periods are women
let's celebrate the diversity of all
people who bleed
myth busting right okay now a few things
here briefly first of all
i have this question that i always ask
uh when this issue comes up and i still
have not gotten
an answer to it i've not gotten a
coherent answer to it but it certainly
is relevant here the question is really
simply
what is a woman can you define the term
define woman um now i know how normal
science believing people define it we
would say that a woman
is an adult human female that simple
that easy
but if you are someone who believes that
men can have periods
not all people with periods are women
then how do you define it
not all people with periods are women
okay well what do you mean by women
do you have a definition and if you
don't have a definition for the term
then why are you using it you shouldn't
be using words you don't know how to
define
because how could you possibly know if
you're using it in the right context so
that's
that's the first point uh the second
point is for the record it is certainly
not a fact um
that some people with periods aren't
women if you believe in menstruating men
that is a dogma that's a doctrine
that is a a an article of faith
that's a creed that's a superstition
it's many things you call it many things
what you cannot call it is a fact and
what you certainly cannot call it is
science
and third point tampax is a major
billion dollar brand
their customer base is exclusively
despite what they claim
exclusively women now what do they gain
by rambling about men with periods
how does this help their business how
many customers will they add
by coming out as a company that believes
in menstruating men
and then you compare that to how many
customers they could potentially lose
with this insanity and you see that they
really have nothing to gain
profit-wise from this they have nothing
to gain whatsoever so why do they do it
well
because this is the cultural power that
the left wields corporations will
actually
forfeit money they will give up money
and they will give up customers
willingly in order to signal their
leftist virtue in order to gain
woke points that's how you know the left
is winning the culture war
that's that that's the hallmark of of
cultural domination when billion dollar
corporations will
give up money just to show that they are
in allegiance with you
um and they've got so if you're on the
left you've got corporations you've got
academia you've got the media you've got
hollywood and so forth all of that on
your side
but even so the left still claims that
they're the the counter culture
leftist activists will will pretend that
they're the counter culture
radicals when they've got everything in
the culture on their side
um so we know that that's that's not the
case but we also know even though they
have the culture on their side
they've got all the corporations they've
got the media academia hollywood
everything we just listed
what they don't have is the truth the
truth remains the truth
and truth is that men are men and they
don't menstruate
and it will never not be tragic
that a statement like men don't
menstruate needs to be said out loud
but it does and it will never not be
tragic
that biological science has to be
defended but it does
and so we must